[Música]
certo dia eu recebi um belo de um
desafio da minha liderança disse assim e
laine nós temos três meses para
contratar 50 pessoas com deficiência
nessa unidade mantendo-as engajados e
dando o seu melhor
vocês devem estar pensando assim é fácil
aliás ótimo nós temos tantas pessoas pra
desempregados no mercado de trabalho e
têm mesmo se sabe quantas pessoas com
deficiência
nós temos em todo o brasil mais de 45
milhões de pessoas dessas você imaginou
quantas delas estão empregadas apenas
350 e duas mil pessoas
mas você sabe o que é mais estranha
atualmente nós temos 15 milhões de
empresas passivas de serem multadas por
não cumprirem a lei de cotas em todo o
brasil
eu fiquei pensando o que faz com que uma
empresa esteja numa situação vulnerável
como essa com tantas pessoas precisamos
trabalhar e eu não vim aqui pra achar
apontar culpados até porque todos nós
que estamos aqui temos alguma
responsabilidade social com esse assunto
eu imagino que é que tenha educadores
profissionais da saúde na área jurídica
engenheiros estudantes donas de casa e
tantas outras profissões ea nossa
própria condição de cidadão que
contribui diretamente para a formação e
informação na pessoa com deficiência
mas hoje eu vim aqui pra contar pra
vocês como foi a minha experiência com
esse assunto
como eu disse para vocês eu tinha uma
meta e para atingi lá eu tinha que
entrevistar
muitas pessoas a primeira delas eu me
deparei com um currículo que dizia assim
pessoa com deficiência auditiva
gente eu logo pensei isso essa pessoa
não houve nada
e se ela não muda como é que uma
entrevista ela seria muito fácil neste
momento é deixar esse currículo de lado
até porque se eu não estava preparada
para entrevistá-la empresa também
estaria para recebê-la é verdade
não na verdade o que a gente faz quando
a gente lida com alguma coisa que a
gente não conhece
quando a gente se depara com um
desconhecido
a gente ignora a gente finge que não vê
não definitivamente não é isso que a
gente tem que fazer até porque a
deficiência ela também é nossa e é
exatamente por isso que eu resolvi nesse
momento que eu precisava de fazer uma
imersão nesse assunto porque eu não
conhecia muita coisa sobre esse desafio
que eu tinha para enfrentar e foi aí que
eu tive uma ideia que foi beber direto
da fonte de pessoas que sabiam falar
sobre pessoas com deficiência
então eu convidei para estar comigo
entidades que cuidam de pessoas com
deficiência instituições de ensino
famílias que lutam pela inclusão dos
seus filhos
líderes da nossa empresa que estavam
extremamente abertos a inclusão de
pessoas com deficiência ea minha própria
equipe claro para que juntos a gente
pudesse resolver como agente cuidaria da
empregabilidade dessas pessoas dentro da
nossa empresa
esse foi um momento importantíssimo
porque foi o encontro que nós quebramos
paradigmas e o primeiro deles foi a
gente se perguntava será mesmo que a
empresa ela precisa estar 100% acessível
para iniciar as nossas contratações
gente é
eram tantas necessidades 15 exigia um
alto investimento muito grande no prédio
e tempo inclusive se lembra tinham
treino tinha três meses e nós decidimos
que nós não iríamos por esse caminho nos
tornaríamos sim a nossa unidade mais
acessível mas a partir da necessidade de
cada pessoa que nós contratássemos e foi
aí que nós contratamos a nossa primeira
pessoa com deficiência visual total
foi uma bela de uma contratação eo pedir
ajuda o ano aquele encontro que eu tive
com as entidades com as instituições
eu perguntei se tinha alguém que pudesse
estar comigo no primeiro dia de
integração dessa pessoa e uma professora
e levantou a mão e disse eu conheço ele
eu posso estar com você e eu me lembro
desse dia como se fosse hoje eu fui
recebê los na recepção da empresa e lá
estava ela com a mão nos ombros dele e
contando os passos para que ele entrasse
na empresa e ela contava os passos e
dizia para ele aqui outro ponto onde
você passa o seu cartão de ponto aqui é
o banco aqui ficam os banheiros
ela ia contando os passos aqui o rh até
nós chegamos a equipe dele
sim porque eu tinha convidado os líderes
dele e toda a equipe dele para recebê lo
nesse dia e foi muito interessante
porque essa professora ela foi um ponto
de apoio para que ele pudesse apresentar
e também as pessoas pudessem esclarecer
suas dúvidas e foi muito interessante
porque as pessoas foram se sentindo à
vontade ele se apresentou até que as
pessoas se dirigiram a professora e fez
uma pergunta sobre ele e ela respondeu
ah sim gente pergunta pra ele e ele sabe
ele não é muito não
a gente foi é fazendo a integração dele
ela fez uma bolinha de papel e colou no
crachá dele e eu muito curiosa pelo
ela falou o crachá de não tem lado é pra
ele não tem lado essa bolinha vai
identificar para ele o lado que ele tem
que passar o ponto dele
gente simples assim você não paradigma
que nós quebramos
foi quando não sabemos como agir com a
pessoa com deficiência o que fazemos é a
próxima pessoa que nós contratamos foi
uma cadeirante foi uma experiência
incrível também eu tinha aprendido que
nós tínhamos que fazer o percurso dela
antes que ela entrasse né no primeiro
dia de trabalho então eu convidei a
liderança dela e mais uma pessoa da
infraestrutura do prédio
fui até o sesi 20 e pegou uma cadeira de
rodas e eu disse para eles assim olha se
tem uma coisa que eu já aprendi que a
gente pra fazer esse percurso pra que a
gente tendo inclusive se tem alguma
necessidade que a gente pode chamar
antes que ela chegue a liderança dela
falou eu não posso sentar naquele
momento eu tive certeza que nós tínhamos
escolhido o melhor líder para ela porque
ele tem empatia todo o resto nós
aprendemos juntos e nós fomos fazendo o
percurso e eu esqueci de dizer pra vocês
que eu também convidou uma pessoa para
estar comigo que era uma terapeuta
ocupacional ela veio voluntariamente
nossa empresa para poder nos ajudar
nessa integração dele também e foi muito
interessante ainda bem que ela estava lá
porque durante o percurso o líder fez
uma pergunta pra mim ele disse assim ela
n é muito bem assim entendendo que a
gente
qual é o percurso e mas e se ela
precisar de um banheiro durante o
expediente é como é que eu faço e gente
era bem provável que ela ia ter um
banheiro é a sorte contas na feria 8
horas da empresa e pode parecer simples
mas eu não sabia muito bem como ele
deveria agir ea terapeuta ocupacional
ela respondeu assim tem gente fica
tranqüilo porque uma cadeirante na maior
parte das vezes
ela fica em pé deixe que elas apoia mas
mais que isso
se vocês tiverem alguma dúvida também
pergunta pra ela
simples assim pergunta pra própria
pessoa o que ela precisa
o terceiro é possível incluir uma pessoa
independente da deficiência pode parecer
engraçado mas os líderes eles têm as
suas preferências em relação à
contratação do tipo de deficiência
a gente prefere pelo desconhecido tá bom
porque a priori
até parece que tem um tipo de
deficiência que mais fácil de trabalhar
do que outra e até que nós contratamos
uma pessoa que ela tinha perda de
memória recente tem idéia de como o que
nós faremos no dia a dia com ela e o
líder dela me fez uma pergunta logo de
cara que foi assim ela necessita de
certeza que vai dar certo a gente
incluir uma pessoa que não recebem
aquilo que a gente ensina rio diz pra
ele eu tinha que passar muita segurança
na gente
eu disse pra ele assim claro eu tenho
certeza disso
e tem uma coisa que você eu posso te
garantir que você não vai ter um
colaborador com visto de trabalho e aí
eu eu precisava de ajuda também está bem
mais uma profissional comigo e essa
profissional ela fez uma lista para ele
do que ele deveria fazer para chegar no
ambiente de trabalho ela disse guarde na
sua carteira e quando ele chegava no
ambiente de trabalho
ele se preparava no seu posto de
trabalho com uma folha de sulfite
florescente e lá estava escrito o que
ele tinha que fazer passo a passo é
claro as atividades dele era
extremamente rotineiras mas não por isso
menos importante o primeiro passo que
estava lá é mega senha com a sua
coordenadora gente é depois desse caso
eu tive certeza que nós conseguimos
incluir qualquer pessoa com qualquer
tipo de
ciência tudo é possível eu garanto para
vocês não foi tão romântico como no
filme como se fosse a primeira vez
mas deu tudo certo finalmente porque as
pessoas com deficiência trocaria o loas
por um trabalho é para quem não sabe o
los é um benefício que o governo oferece
para as pessoas que não são aptas a
trabalhar e nós fomos entrevistar várias
pessoas e tinham muitas delas que possui
um benefício e elas seriam ótimas para
trabalhar conosco mas elas tinham muito
medo de perder o benefício e não dá
certo no ambiente de trabalho e nós
enquanto empresa também não podíamos
garantir nós percebíamos inclusive é
através das famílias que viviam junto
que muitas vezes a própria família tinha
muito mais receio do que a própria
pessoa com deficiência e com toda razão
eles sabiam como tinha sido difícil
conseguir aquele benefício até que nós
conhecemos uma jovem ela é uma jovem
cadeirante e ela tinha um brilho nos
olhos também queria muito trabalhar e
ela dizia olha eu quero você dessa vaga
eo pai dela do lado dizia assim não
filha eu acho que é melhor eu não tiver
essa vaga se vai pedir o benefício
imagina ela não dá garantia estabilidade
é verdade
a empresa não podia garantir isso a ela
o pai eu quero sair de casa eu quero
mais
eu percebi que tinha um mundo na frente
dessa menina que ela ainda não conhecia
foi aí que a gente teve uma brilhante
ideia e durante ideia porque deu muito
certo
a gente pensou por que não colocar lá e
tantos outros que nós tínhamos conhecido
como jovens aprendizes com deficiência
porque enquanto jovens aprendizes e
teria um contrato por período
determinado
então a possibilidade de ele perder o
benefício era mínima e assim ela topou a
gente não é essa pessoa ela não entraria
para a cota de pessoas com deficiência
porque ela já estaria na cota de jovem
aprendiz
mas a gente resolveu enquanto empresa
fazer esse investimento
e a gente contratou dez pessoas como
jovens aprendizes nessa condição e foi
um projeto que foi um sucesso e no final
de um ano eles escolheram se eles
queriam continuar conosco não o quinto
paradigma que nós quebramos foi mas será
que a pessoa com deficiência é produtivo
é a gente porque quem é líder aqui sabe
que o dia a dia da empresa é real e
existem muitas metas para serem
atingidas muitas metas e eles queriam
sim eles já estavam abertos aquela a
inclusão das pessoas com deficiência mas
eles queriam ajuda para que a gente
acelerar se a integração delas
e pra quem inclusive aos elas pudessem
ser cada vez mais produtivas e suas
áreas
e foi aí que eu convoquei três pessoas
três profissionais
uma assistente social uma terapeuta
ocupacional e uma psicopedagoga para que
viesse nos ajudar e fazer parte do nosso
do nosso time a ser social ela tinha
responsabilidade de cuidar de todos os
direitos dessa pessoa enquanto cidadão
com deficiência na cidade ela garantia
locomoção saúde é educação muito os
nossos colaboradores com deficiência
voltaram a estudar inclusive depois a
terapeuta posso a psicopedagoga atende a
pessoa e ela tinha o grande desafio de
fazer uma avaliação de qual era a melhor
forma de ensinar essa pessoa como era a
melhor forma de aprender a terceira
pessoa que atendia era terapeuta
ocupacional atleta profissional ela
ficava no posto de trabalho da pessoa e
já com todos todo briefing que foi
passado pelo ela sim social e pela
psicopedagoga ela ajudava a pessoa
criando estratégias para que ela
entregasse suas metas
esse programa esse projeto ele acontece
há três anos
hoje ele se tornou um programa e ele se
chama programa alta performance assim
porque todos eles atingiram 100% do seu
melhor
esse percentual ele não é estável e eu
pergunto a vocês quem aqui estava o seu
paradigma foi psi começar sensibilizando
os líderes
eu diria que eu não sei se a palavra
sensibilizando é a melhor expressão
porque qualquer contratação ela não era
opcional
era uma cota agora eu posso garantir
para vocês nós tivemos líderes que foram
exemplos e que contagiaram a nossa
unidade
demonstrando o quanto era possível que a
inclusão acontecesse
e mais que isso esse projeto ele não foi
um projeto do rh
ele era um projeto da companhia e por
isso deu tão certo e por fim o último
paradigma é quem disse que só pessoas
com deficiência precisam de condições
especiais
todos nós aqui em algum momento da nossa
vida
tivemos alguma condição especial quando
nós estamos com nossas crianças
quando nós ficamos grávidas quando nós
passamos por alguma cirurgia algum
acidente
quando nós ficamos idosos por isso todos
nós somos beneficiados com uma sociedade
inclusiva
pois é uma sociedade que enxerga o outro
como indivíduo único portanto o respeito
à diversidade
a nossa quota foi atingida mas a nossa
meta era muito maior do que essa cota
nós queríamos que a inclusão ela fosse
efetiva de verdade esse processo não foi
natural esse processo exigiu muita
coragem e determinação por parte de
todas as pessoas envolvidas claro foi um
processo que valeu muito a pena
muito obrigado
[Música]